13.000 Menschen sind laut Polizei
gekommen zum sogenannten Aufstand für
den Frieden extrem rechter
afd-funktionäre Nato-Gegner
russlandfreunde sogenannte Querdenker
mehrheitlich aber ein friedensbewegtes
eher bürgerliches Milieu für
Verhandlungen gegen weitere
Waffenlieferungen der Vizekanzler
verurteilt die Kundgebung noch bevor sie
stattgefunden hat das ist kein Frieden
das ist eine Chimäre die da aufgebaut
wird ist eine politische Irreführung der
Bevölkerung das ist keinen Weg für
Verhandlungen gibt wollen die meisten
Menschen hier nicht glauben viele fühlen
sich die vermehrt ihnen fehlt in der
Friedensfrage heute die politische
Repräsentation
fühle ich mich da nicht im Moment
irgendwie
an der ganzen Sache dass man sich für
Frieden rechtfertigen muss es ist dieses
Gefühl in einem verengten Diskurs nicht
mehr vorzukommen dass sich Sarah
Wagenknecht politisch zu Nutze macht
seit wann ist der Ruf nach Frieden der
Ruf nach Diplomatie und Verhandlungen
rechts und kriegsbesoffenheit ist dann
wohl links einige haben ja offenbar
völlig ihren politischen Kompass
verloren unter den 69 erst unterzeichnen
des Friedens Aufrufs ein breites
Spektrum von Historikern wie Peter
Brandt über Politiker wie Peter
Gauweiler bis zur Schauspielern wie
Katharina Thalbach es ist aber vor allem
Wagenknecht die polarisiert die Linke
Parteispitze hatte sich im Vorfeld von
der Demo distanziert die Flanke nach
rechts sei nicht geschlossen schadet
Wagenknecht als umstrittene Figur nicht
auch der Friedensbewegung zunächst mal
glaube ich nicht dass die
Friedensbewegung Schaden nimmt wenn es
endlich mal eine richtig große
Friedensdemonstration gibt und die
Debatte die teilweise von der linke
Führung hier angestoßen wurde also ich
muss sagen ich fand das einfach nur
blamabel also man hat im Grunde die
Einschüchterung die ist dort gab
gegenüber den Menschen
mitgemacht
jenseits von Parteipolitik aber geht der
Riss in der Friedensfrage längst auch
durch die gesellschaftliche linke Bernd
stiegemann war mal ein Weggefährte von
Wagenknecht in der Frage Krieg und
Frieden hat er sich abgewendet von mir
Frieden heißt ja dann nur dass die
militärischen Waffen schweigen aber wie
wir an Butcher und all den anderen
Kriegsverbrechen gesehen haben geht der
geht die Gewalt auf einer anderen Ebene
ja dann weiter das ist quasi der große
blinde Fleck um sich zu sein die große
Lüge in diesen Friedens aufrufen die
einfach behaupten wenn die großen Waffen
schweigen dann sei auch Frieden für die
Bevölkerung das ist es ja dann gerade
nicht
Solidarität mit der Ukraine so sieht die
andere große Friedensdemo in Berlin am
Freitag aus knapp 10.000 Menschen viele
Regierungsvertreter auch ein gegenaufruf
zu Wagenknecht ist längst verfasst der
CDU Abgeordnete Kiesewetter hat ihn auf
den Weg gebracht darin ist fast
verächtlich von friedenskünstlern um
Wagenknecht und schwarzer die Rede es
sei erschreckend aus der Mitte unserer
Gesellschaft zuzusehen wie die rechts
und links populistischen Pole den Kreis
schließen
so einfach aber ist es nicht auch die
Mitte der Gesellschaft ist ja bei
Wagenknecht und schwarzer vertreten
wir sehen eben auch viele die eventuell
aus der Mitte der Gesellschaft sich dort
anschließen weil sie Angst haben weil
sie die
potenziellen Auswirkungen der Lieferung
von Waffen auch der Fortsetzung des
Krieges fürchten und dass sie auch
fürchten dass der Krieg eventuell nach
Deutschland überschwappt insofern haben
wir hier eine sehr Hybride Konstellation
sehr unterschiedlicher Gruppen der
protestforscher Alexander Leistner
beobachtet seit Jahren Friedensbewegung
er sieht einen konsenszwang in der
aktuellen Debatte und warnt davor die
klassische Friedensbewegung aus dem
Diskurs rauszubringen
ja was man eben beobachten konnte das
ist recht früh nach dem Krieg Ebenen
sehr starke vereindeutung gab in den
Positionen quasi also das ist das
sozusagen pazifistische Position sehr
schnell als lumpenpazifismus bezeichnet
wurde und wiederum Positionen die auf
eine Unterstützung der Ukraine
hinauslaufen als belizismus
Polizisten also Kriegstreiber gegen
lumpenpazifisten die die jetzt für
Frieden auf die Straße gehen stehen sich
in härter werdenden Fronten gegenüber
und bei mir im Studio begrüße ich jetzt
einen der sich mitten in diese Debatte
hineinbegeben hat den CDU außen und
Sicherheitspolitiker und mit Initiator
der Petition Gegenrede schön guten Abend
Roderich Kiesewetter
wir haben es eben im Beitrag gehört und
aber auch in vielen Debatten Beiträgen
in dieser Woche gesehen es gibt viele
Menschen die sind von dem Krieg
beunruhigt die haben Angst vor einer
Eskalationsspirale die machen sich auch
Sorgen um die eigenen sicher um die
eigene Sicherheit die leiden auch mit
mit den Menschen in der Ukraine mit
ihrer Petition wischen Sie deren Ängste
praktisch alle beiseite warum ich wische
keine Ängste beiseite sondern uns geht
es wirklich darum dass die Gesellschaft
zusammen bleibt entscheidend ist dass
wir gegenseitig ein Verständnis dafür
entwickeln wer Täter und wer Opfer ist
wir müssen uns vorstellen hier ist ein
Land in der Mitte Europas angegriffen
und wir wollen nicht dass ein
Scheinfrieden entsteht in dem die Waffen
schweigen wenn Russland aufhört zu
kämpfen ist der Krieg vorbei wenn die
Ukraine aufhört zu kämpfen ist das Land
vorbei sie bedienen sich ihre Petition
einer sehr deutlichen Sprache des die
Petition muss man sagen ist mittlerweile
von deutlich über 600.000 Menschen
unterschrieben worden zu den
Erstunterzeichnern gehören namhafte
Persönlichkeiten aus der Gesellschaft
die nie als Demokratie Feinde
aufgefallen sind all diese Menschen
bezeichnen sie gemeinsam unter dem
Begriff friedenskünstler warum diese
abwertende Begriff friedenskünstler ist
kein abwertender Begriff aber der
Frieden ist eine Kunst und uns geht es
darum dass die Ukraine hier nicht als
Opfer gesehen wird sondern in diesem
Aufruf Täter und Opfer gleichgestellt
werden das wäre so wir werden ihr
Nachbarhaus überfallen wird der Mann
getötet die Kinder entführt und der Frau
die vergewaltigt worden ist gesagt wird
macht Platz in deinem Haus und das führt
verharmlosend dieses Manifest von Sahra
Wagenknecht die rechts und
Linksextremisten zusammenführt und ich
glaube auch die demokratische Mitte ein
bisschen ausnutzt mit dem Begriff
Frieden führt hier nicht zu Lösung das
ist der Knackpunkt Künstler ist so ein
Begriff den man auch den sozialen Medien
findet viele haben sich davon
herabgesetzt gefühlt haben wir gelesen
wir hatten auch in dieser Woche noch
eine andere Debatte Jürgen Habermas
hatte sich zu Wort gemeldet und auch er
ist nicht sehr freundlich bedacht worden
man ist nicht so ganz auf seine
Argumente eingegangen mein Kollege Robin
alexander hat das zusammengefasst mit
ihm wurde mit Häme Witzeleien und
moralischen Herabsetzung begegnet dass
der Mann war mal eine Autorität in der
öffentlichen Debatte und wird jetzt so
behandelt wie will man mehr Menschen
dafür gewinnen sich in solch wichtigen
Debatten einzumischen wenn man so mit
den Leuten umgeht ich glaube sie
erkennen worum es wirklich geht es geht
darum ob die Ukraine als Staat überlebt
und wenn wir die Ukraine zu einem
einseitigen Waffenstillstand aufrufen
gewinnt Russland russland hat sehr klar
gemacht dass der Krieg weiter getragen
wird wenn die Ukraine gewonnen wird geht
es gegen Moldau uns geht's darum dass
wir verhindern Kriegspartei zu werden
die Ursache des Ganzen ist doch dass
unser Bundeskanzler zu wenig erklärt hat
über sechs Monate gab es einen Planungs-
und diskussionsverbot es gab rote Linien
über Kampfpanzer und dass die Ukraine
gewinnen muss wir müssen sehr deutlich
unsere Bevölkerung sagen es steht auf
dem Spiel dass die Ukraine überlebt es
geht darum dass die Ukraine gewinnt mit
ihren Grenzen von 1991 und die Russische
Föderation verlieren lernt ihre
kolonialen Ansprüche aufgibt und auch
aufgibt Menschen zu vergewaltigen Frauen
zu vergewaltigen 100.000 Kinder
nachgewiesen zu entführen darum geht es
und nicht ob Herr habermaß sich
beleidigt fühlt oder nicht also wirklich
das wird am Ziel vorbei diese Wetter
wenn man den Blick ein wenig weitet und
mal über Berlin und dann habermaß
hinausgeht dann sehen wir dass es
Friedensdemonstration jetzt am
Wochenende gab in 20 Städten da gab es
auch ganz breit angelegte Forderungen
die unter anderem auch das enthalten was
Sie gesagt haben das sind Menschen die
für ihr Anliegen in der politischen
Mitte keine Ansprechpartner mehr finden
welches Angebot machen Sie diesen Leuten
die sagen lass uns darüber sprechen wie
man die Waffen zum Schweigen bringen
kann die Waffen werden erst dann
schweigen wenn die Ukraine die Chance
hat in eine Verhandlungsposition zu
kommen das bedeutet dass die Ukraine so
viele Waffen bekommt dass sie ihr
Territorium befreien kann dass die
Kriegsverbrechen ein Ende haben das
Russland die waffenstrecken muss und das
werden wir nicht indem wir die Krim
befreien sondern indem die
Versorgungslinien zur Krim zerschlagen
werden und die russischen Truppen dort
aufgeben ich war selbst jetzt auf vier
Demonstrationen auch am Wochenende in
meinem Wahlkreis bei hunderten Menschen
die Menschen haben eine friedensehnsucht
aber sie stehen an der Seite der Ukraine
und der geschundenen Bevölkerung und
nicht an der verharmlosenden
unterlassenen Hilfeleistung die Frau
Wagenknecht ist will das heißt aktuell
machen sie da noch keine Hoffnung darauf
dass sie auf einen Dialog über
Friedensverhandlungen eingehen der
Dialog über Friedensverhandlungen ist
von Russland abgelehnt worden die
Ukraine wollte die Krim aufgeben die
Ukraine wollte die NATO-Mitgliedschaft
als Ziel aufgeben die Ukraine wollte
sogar die besetzten Gebiete von Russland
von 2013 aufgeben und die Antwort von
Russland war Butcher irritin mariopol
furchtbare Kriegsverbrechen das ist mein
Appell an unsere Bevölkerung dass wir
begreifen dass wir mit ungleichen Waffen
gearbeitet wird die Ukraine ist der
Angegriffene der Unterlegene wenn die
Ukraine aufhört zu kämpfen dann ist
unsere Freiheit bedroht weil Russland
weiterkämpft und uns in den Krieg ziehen
will das müssen wir verhindern
Sicherheitspolitiker und mit Initiator
der Petition Gegenrede herzlichen Dank
für das Gespräch